CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
One of the principles of cartoon
animation that we
spoke about recently at a Google
I/O talk called "A
Moving Experience" is the idea
that motion in our real world
is not linear.
So if you want a UI to feel more
natural to the user, more
organic, more like it's a
real-world application, then
maybe the motion in your
application shouldn't be
linear either.
Now, we already offer this
by default in all of the
animations in the platform in
terms of time interpolators,
because you can set deceleration
motion,
acceleration motion,
overshooting.
By default, you accelerate into
and out of any animation.
So the time aspect is
already handled.
So that feels a little bit
more natural than simple
linear interpolation.
However, the motion on the
screen is not handled
automatically.
If you want to move, let's say,
a view from the upper
left side of the screen down to
the lower right side of the
screen, and you want it to
follow a curve instead of a
straight line, it may
not be immediately
obvious how to do that.
So this is why I wrote
an article a
while ago on my blog.
My blog is at
graphics-geek.blogspot.com.
The article is called "Curved
Motion in Android."
So you can go check
out that article.
It's basically most of what I'm
going to be showing today.
So you can go read that
for more information.
But I wanted to give a brief
glimpse of how you would do
that using the existing
animation APIs that we already
offer in the platform.
So we can take a look at
the following demo.
Very simple--
we have a boring button on the
upper left side of the screen.
And now, it's a boring
button on the lower
right side of the screen.
So these are two different
layouts where we determine
where the button needs to
be in the two positions.
And we basically just
toggle between them.
But as we toggle between them,
we animate the position change
using the approach that
I'll go over in the
code starting now.
OK, so in our click listener,
we call this method called
Move Button here.
This simply sets the layout
parameters to tell the button
to be either at the upper
left or lower right--
very straightforward.
Then we add an
OnPreDrawListener, which is a
technique that I use a lot
in animation demos, which
basically allows layout to run
from the previous change.
In this case, we set the layout
parameters on the view.
Layout is going to run.
And then it's going to change
the position of the button.
But before we draw that change
on the screen, we're going to
figure out where the
button is now.
We know where it was before,
because we track that in these
oldLeft and oldTop properties
up here.
And now we can figure out the
delta between those, between
the x and the y values, and
animate the change.
Now, if all we did was set up an
animation to animate x and
animate y, it's very
easy to set up.
But it's going to give you the
linear motion that simply
moves the button linearly
from the upper left
to the lower right.
And we really wanted the
curved motion instead.
So we're going to use some
helper classes in here.
We're going to use this Animator
Path class that I've
defined that's similar to, but
much simpler than, the path
object that we provide
in the framework.
It also has a query capability
that will return this array of
points, which is sort
of important for the
interpolation that I needed
to do with it.
So in the Animator Path, you can
basically use one of three
methods to set up your path.
You can do a Move To, a Line
To, and a Curve To.
So I'm going to tell the path to
move to the old position of
the button, and then
curve to the new
position of the button.
And the arguments to the Curve
To are both the end position
as well as a couple of control
points in the middle.
And this is basically defining
a cubic Bezier spline between
the two points.
We have anchor points at the end
and control points in the
middle that determine the motion
of that object along
this curve.
In this case, it's a simple
curve that's just going to go
in a simple arc down to the
lower right and then back to
the upper left.
We create an Object Animator
on our objects.
And we're going to animate
this property called
buttonLoc, which I've defined
a property setter for, which
we'll see below.
We're going to use this path
evaluator, which is a class I
defined to evaluate
between these
different types of objects.
One of the nice things about the
property animation system
is, sure, you can animate
floats and ints.
But sometimes, you have
a more complex data
structure like a [? rept ?]
or a point, or in this case,
these path objects, these path
points along the curve.
Then how would you interpolate
along those?
Well, the system doesn't
know how to.
But you can tell it how to by
providing one of these type
evaluators to get a callback
on every frame.
And then you simply do the
interpolation for the system
and pass back the appropriate
values.
And then finally, for the points
that we're going to
animate between, we do a query
into our animator path.
And that's going to return
this array of points that
define the animation.
We set an interpolator
on this thing.
And we start.
And we're all good to go.
So we can take a look
at the bottom.
We have this property setter
that we need to find called
setButtonLoc.
This is going to get this object
called PathPoint, which
is a data structure that
holds the information.
And then we simply set the
TranslationX and TranslationY
property of the view according
to what was in
that PathPoint object.
We can take a look at
the PathPoints.
This is simply a data structure
that says, what kind
of point is this?
It's a move or a line or
a curve, and then has
information about those
points internally.
The animator path that we saw
before allows you to build up
this path of successive points
and then query the points once
you're done so we can actually
set up the animation on it.
And then finally, we have
the type evaluator.
And the one that we defined
is called Path Evaluator.
And it just uses this
straightforward calculation.
So it looks like a lot of
garbage going on in here.
This is actually a really
simple calculation.
It's a standard spline
calculation.
So given a value t, the time
in this animation, we can
calculate the x and y
values on the curve.
One caveat that I mention in the
article as well is this is
not necessarily the motion along
the curve that you want.
What you really want is, in
general, to take the t value
of how far along the curve is,
and use that to extract your x
and y values.
That requires a little
bit more code.
I didn't want to get into it
in this simple example.
The effect that you'd get by
using this simplistic approach
here is, on hairpin turns,
you'd go a lot faster.
So you really want to spread
out that motion
evenly along the curve.
Kind of a detail--
maybe it'll matter in
some of your curves.
So you should know about it.
But if you want a simple
approach, here's one.
So curved motion-- in general,
if you're moving stuff on the
screen that's not just going in
one axis, consider moving
it in a curve to give the user
more of a natural and organic
feeling for your application.
Make them feel like they're
actually interacting with
something in the real world
instead of just some user
interface on a boring screen.
Thanks.